welcome to Carnegie Mellon online for
more multimedia from Carnegie Mellon
University visit w WC mu edu slash
multimedia
the idea of this panel came up well it
just happened that I was reviewing a
paper on technologies for carbon dioxide
reduction that the Institute of Defense
analysis in their signs and Technology
Policy Institute was preparing for the
Office of Science and Technology Policy
at the White House and I kept seeing
reference to CMU research Granger's name
Lester's name Ed's name carbon
sequestration and I thought this is very
interesting and then it came up that I
was asked to participate on the
committee for the homecoming our 50th
anniversary here graduates from CMU and
the opportunity to present some panels
sponsored by the class of nineteen
fifty-seven and so I said well I think
we should do on climate control global
climate because it's a hot topic and
maybe we ought to think about
nanotechnology so as the class has
decided that we would do those two
things so and then simultaneously I was
called by some very committed scientists
in Washington about this climate
commitment program that Middlebury and
Harvard we're talking about and this
idea was that they would get their alums
as they came in to the reunions to think
about what they could do to encourage
their universities to make global
climate and energy efficiency one of
their priorities and I thought who I
don't have to do that with CMU they're
teaching us that and then another the
CMU magazine came and there was this
great article on cool ideas by Mike
Randall featuring grandeur and and
increasingly you know we see more and
more about this so I called Lester and
said how about a panel and he said oh I
think that's a great idea and then
Granger said yes and by the way if we
want to talk about carbon sequestration
we certainly have to have ed so that was
the basis and then we have another
participant which I'll introduce his bio
shortly so with all that in mind the
source came to sort of together in a
line and then I was called by the
university to tell them today and and
add they asked me about the Steinbrenner
Institute for environmental education
research and I had
heard of this and so Deb Lang talked to
me about G we've produced for the last
two years we put on environmental
seminar and I said well great why don't
we sponsor this together and so David
Deb have just been terrific and and
their staff and so as part of this what
I'd like you to do is pick up this
little brochure that we put together
that tells you as individuals what you
can do to begin to think about climate
control in your own house in your
neighborhood I mean we're really smart
people and we can influence our
legislators but they need to know that
we're interested in this area so what
I'd suggest is you take this brochure go
home think about what you can do in your
communities to help change some ways
people are doing business think about
schools in your neighborhood how they
can begin to teach kids about climate
control issues and so forth so pick this
up on your way out the steinbrenner
Institute helped put this together and I
appreciate your support net so let's uh
proceed on with the panel then so first
I'd like to introduce dr. Granger Morgan
and he has a oh one thing I forgot to
tell you that I wanted to mention mm-hmm
and that was of course that looks who
I'm sorry I miss mm-hmm of course the
fact that elbow al gore received the
Nobel Prize didn't her and also that ed
Ruben was participating on one of the
panels that has also received the Nobel
Prize which we'll talk a little bit more
but those of you who Dave mentioned an
article by Tom Friedman but I happen to
see one in the New York Times about a
week or two ago and Tom Friedman wrote
about one council member in the city of
New York who got together with an
entrepreneur with the idea of changing
the taxi fleet and they with some they
encourage the council in this new city
of New York to buy 500 taxis that were
hybrids these were four desks X escapes
and then with great support from major
Bloomberg they then proceeded to get a
requirements and new legislation that
says from now on all new taxis will be
green taxis so they're going to have
something like 15,000
it's in New York City in time that will
be hybrid taxis that will be gas
efficient and the taxi drivers love it
because it saves them money on gas and
so his comment was if New York goes
green the Big Apple goes green people
come to New York 40 billion people tort
for into the city ride in a green taxi
they'll go home and say gee why don't we
have green taxis in our neighborhood so
this is one example of one person with
an entrepreneur support saying I can
make a change in my neighborhood so I
just wanted to call your attention to
the fact that you have a lot of power in
your own neighborhoods in your own
school environments and so good to to
make some changes so that's what this
panel is all about you'll get some
suggestions so first I'd like to
introduce Granger Morgan who's professor
and head of the department of
engineering and public policy he's the
University and Lord chair professor and
engineering he has appointments in
electrical engineering Johnson School of
Public Policy and management and he's
the director of the NSF climate division
making center at CMU and co-directors
with Lester lay the Carnegie Mellon
electricity industry center his research
addresses problems in science and
technology in public policy with an
emphasis on characterizing and treating
uncertainty in quantitative policy
analysis dr. Granger serves as head of
the Advisory Committee vpa which I
certainly appreciate and the chair of
the upper e advisory board he is
graduate of Harvard College with a major
in physics and an MS in cornell and PhD
from the University of California at San
Diego he's been elected the national
academy of sciences and the steinbrenner
newsletter has a special feature on that
so and that's because he's been a
consistent voice in the nation to curb
co2 emissions so dr. bender and Morgan
sorry
thanks very much actually in addition to
New York Purdue people may be able to
tell us about how New Delhi succeeded in
cleaning up its air by switching all of
its three wheelers from cheap high
sulfur fuel to a natural gas it's made a
dramatic change I thought that I that I
should start with a little bit of
overview of the basic science and then
ed and Lester will respectively talk
about controlling emissions from power
plants and controlling emissions from
the transportation sector you probably
most of you know the basic ideas behind
climate science but but I continue to be
surprised by how when i briefed folks
like for example a recent briefing I did
for a FERC Commissioner some very
fundamental things have been missed and
so pardon me while I just quickly go
through a bit of an overview I mean
energy comes in from the Sun most of it
of course in the form of light some of
it in the form of infrared and about
thirty percent of that is immediately
reflected off the clouds and off the
land and other things the other seventy
percent gets absorbed by the clouds the
atmosphere on the ground now if that
just kept being absorbed of course we'd
all keyed up and fry so we have to get
it back out into space in order for the
same amount of energy to be coming going
back out as comes in and that's where
life gets a little complicated because
while the atmosphere is transparent to
light which of course is why our eyes
evolved to be able to see in good light
it's largely opaque for infrared because
of absorption lines from both the water
vapor but then also carbon dioxide and
that means then that the heat energy
gets trapped and sort of goes round and
round until the whole temperature the
planet warms up just enough so that the
amount of infrared radiated off the top
of the atmosphere
is just equal to the amount of sunlight
being absorbed by the system and the
planet reaches an equilibrium it's a
good thing for us because if this
weren't the case would be a rather
unpleasant cold planet and this is a way
the so-called greenhouse effect is why
earth is a nice place to live now of
course most of that energy comes in at
the equators and the poles would be much
colder than they are and the equators
rather hotter if it weren't for the fact
that a lot of it then gets redistributed
around the planet about half of it gets
moved Pole words with the atmosphere
shown in the upper picture there and
then about the other half gets moved
Paul word through ocean currents and
i'll come back to ocean currents with an
example in a few minutes now we've been
burning lots of coal and oil and natural
gas and when you burn those things of
course the carbon in them combines with
oxygen in the atmosphere and produces
carbon dioxide and the consequence has
been that as the bottom as the top curve
there shows since the Industrial
Revolution began carbon dioxide
concentrations in the atmosphere had
been going up and up that's also true of
a variety of other greenhouse gases that
is gases that absorb carbon dioxide and
the consequence has been then that the
planet has been warming now all of this
is a little abstract so I have recently
started to trying to make the idea
rather more concrete just west of us
here is the Bruce Mann field power plant
it's a little over 2,000 megawatts now
the call for that plan of course
actually comes in in barges but it's
it's much more visual to you to think in
terms of hundred ton hopper cars a plant
like that burns about 230 hopper cars of
coal every day and coal is of course not
pure carbon there's ash in it as well if
I only considered the carbon that would
be about a hundred and thirty hundred
hopper cars a day so every time you see
a coal train with 130 cars a Bruce
Mansfield plant is taking that much mass
combining it with oxygen and sticking it
in the atmosphere every day and we've
got of course hundreds of plants of this
sort all around the world so the mass
involved is really pretty substantial
now the steady buildup of greenhouse
gases of course has resulted in some
warming about one and a half degrees
Fahrenheit or one and a third degrees
Fahrenheit over the last century and the
IPCC recently noted that you can see
that sort of warming in all parts of the
world now the key point I wanted to make
and this is where at least some of you
may have not quite figured it out from
at least press coverage because the
press is often fairly confused about
this issue is that carbon dioxide isn't
like conventional air pollutants if I
put sulfur dioxide or oxides of nitrogen
into the atmosphere they don't stay
there very long a few hours to a few
days so if I stabilize emissions of
those gases I stabilize concentrations
in the atmosphere for those gases that's
not true of carbon dioxide carbon
dioxide lives in the atmosphere much of
it for a hundred years or more and so if
I stabilize emissions concentrations are
just going to continue to build up and
build up if I want to stabilize
concentrations and of course it's the
concentrations that matter in terms of
absorbing the outgoing infrared I have
to reduce emissions by something of the
order of eighty percent a planet-wide
and that in course implies enormous
changes in the operation of the planets
energy systems which is why we're going
to have two talks following this one on
on two important aspects of the energy
system here's a useful an analogy
imagine a bathtub with a very big faucet
and a very small drain and this is
basically what's what's happening in the
Earth's
fear now is a key corollary you often
hear people argue ah well until China
and India and Brazil do something we
shouldn't do anything well sooner or
later China and India are going to have
to get on board but remember I said its
concentration that matters and so what
I've plotted actually J apt has plotted
on the right here are two curves the
right-hand curve is emissions and
actually it turns out China's emissions
have been growing a little more rapidly
than people thought they're probably
just about the same as America's
admissions today but because we've been
at it for a whole lot longer than the
Chinese our contribution to
concentration is much larger and China's
contribution won't catch up with ours
until roughly the middle of the century
which is not to say of course that China
and India and other developing countries
don't need to do anything it is to say
however that we really need to go first
and lead the way show how these
technologies can be made cost-effective
this graphic on the left is a lovely
piece that the artist for the Pittsburgh
post-gazette produced when a couple of
us wrote an opinion piece on this
subject and you can see these blue
molecules which are us carbon dioxide
molecules and the red ones which are to
imply Chinese of molecules it's nice
when an artist actually reads the
opinion piece and produces a so isn't
there enormous uncertainty about the
about climate change yeah there is but
there's no uncertainty about whether
carbon dioxide and other greenhouse
gases are warming the planet and
changing the climate and talk about
uncertainty to be frank is basically the
result of the intentional obfuscation of
those with short-term economic interests
I mean there this has gotten better
recently I mean it was a period a decade
or so ago when there was sort of a
united front across the industry on this
but in the electricity industry for
example first those with lots of nuclear
power broke ranks and now a bunch of
major coal companies have also begun to
figure out that this is a real kool
based utilities have begun to figure out
this is a really
serious problem and we got to start
working on it the same is true in in the
oil industry ExxonMobil is one of the
last holdouts and even they of course
for years have had really good technical
understanding of all of this but have
done their best to obfuscate now there
is uncertainty about how much greenhouse
gas humans will add to the atmosphere
over the next century how much
additional warming that's going to
produce in the details of many changes
and climate and ecosystems and so on so
let me just give you three quick
examples it's still very unclear whether
and how climate change may affect the
frequency in the intensity and track of
hurricanes as a matter of fact later
this morning i'm meeting with a german
postdoc i have who has been doing a very
extensive review of this state of the
science on this and the state of the
science is that we still can't tell I
mean in the long run there are plausible
arguments for why climate change could
have an effect particularly on the
intensity of hurricanes but to date it's
unclear it's also unclear whether and
how much climate change will affect the
ocean conveyor about this large
circulatory system or the balls are
known as the Atlantic Myrtle overturning
circulation and here are some results
from a an analysis that we did jointly
with some folks at the Potsdam Institute
for climate research we were detailed
interviews expert elicitation zeeeee
with with leading oceanographers all
around the world and so what's plotted
there is this is your eyes by the end of
the century this is each experts
judgment of the probability that that
circulatory pattern will shut down or at
least we'll have started to shut down
where r collapse by which we meant a
reduction of ninety percent or more in
intensity and you can see here's an area
where the field is is basically split
now you might ask so what what
difference does it make and I simply
remind you that both central Labrador
and southern England are exactly the
same latitude and while this is not the
only phenomena that contributes to their
being palm trees and subtropical gardens
in southern England it
it is clearly a major factor and here's
the third example fine particles high in
the atmosphere reflect back into space
and so if we took away and we put a lot
of fine particles up there from the
sulfur and power plant fuels and other
things if we reflected less of that's on
my back then we would this would unmask
some warming so we did an analysis also
with 24 leading aerosol physicists and
these things are our box plots that show
the amount of forcing down is cooling
and then the red bar up is the estimate
of how much warming is being contributed
by carbon dioxide and you can see that
if you look at the at the the open dots
in the cooling you can see that there's
probably quite a lot of worming being
offset by the cooling effect of aerosols
last thing I wanted to talk about before
I turn it over to my colleagues is a few
words about impacts the largest amount
of warming of course is going to occur
at the poles and our models out there
now that suggests that the Arctic Ocean
may be completely free of sea ice by the
end of this century this is a result of
a run of a Canadian model there on the
bottom and there are here are some NASA
and NOAA actual illustrations of the
extent of sea ice cover by the overtime
notice that there's still sea ice right
up against northern Greenland and that's
important because if that goes away then
that will result in even further warming
of Greenland now while the archaea is
vulnerable so to our small island states
and coastal estuaries because of sea
level rise mangrove swamps and your
reaction might be who cares about
mangroves well it turns out that this is
the breeding ground for many many
aquatic species alpine meadows why
because
as climate warms they'll be driven right
off the top of mountains and coral reefs
both warming and also sea level rise are
already having significant effects on
coral reefs now as you can maybe tell I
grew up in in New England and the other
effect will be impacts on many
ecosystems that we hold dear I grew up
for example in central New Hampshire and
the notion of New Hampshire my
great-great-great grandchildren may find
New Hampshire with yellow pine and oak
just fine but the notion that there
won't be a sugar maple birch and white
pine I find really quite disturbing now
water expands as it heats not very much
but a little bit and the oceans are big
and so there has been a regular increase
in global sea level those estimates are
the ones just published by the fourth
assessment it says Working Group one
yeah that's right working group one of I
PCC fourth assessment up but what these
guys did not think about or at least
didn't write about was the fact that
there are some new studies suggesting
that Greenland may be losing its ice cap
a lot faster than anybody had thought
now sea ice if you melt it doesn't
change the level it's like you know if
you have a ice cube and a drink and it
melts the drink level doesn't change but
there is growing evidence that we're
seeing rapid melt on Greenland and
furthermore evidence that that some of
that water rather than just running off
the top goes down underneath lubricates
the underside of the ice and accelerates
its loss and so I have I'm going to end
with a lovely slide that Dan shrug at
Harvard produced picked your your
favorite place or along the Gulf Coast
or in South Florida and now I'm going to
melt half of Greenland that's about
three and a half meters of sea level and
I'll cycle back and forth
incidentally in the introduction it was
explained that I chair EPA signs
advisory board and and a few years ago
in region six down down here in in in
this part we got a briefing on all the
wonderful things the agency was doing to
restore coastal wetlands in all of these
things along here and I asked them you
know spending millions of their dollars
and other people's dollars and I asked
them you know what have you how much
have you thought about the implications
of of global warming and sea level rise
in the answer was not at all now if
you've not seen it and you're interested
in learning more about impacts on the US
though it's now a few years old the the
US National Assessment published just at
the very end of the Clinton
administration is still really quite
good you can find it online just do a
search for US National Assessment and
Google will produce it for you it's also
been published by Cambridge University
Press it was a big flap when the bush
administration came in trying to
suppress this document but it's quite a
nice piece and it goes through and talks
about a wide variety of impacts it also
talks about impacts in in regions all
around the country with that I'm going
to call things to a close and Ed are you
going to go next to talk about the
electricity sector which is the single
largest sector producing carbon dioxide
and then Lester will talk a bit about
automobiles and as Lester may explain
the two are actually linked because one
of the promising technologies for
dealing with the emissions from
automobiles is a plug electric hybrids
let me just give a little introduction
ed you're going to go next in mmm dr.
Reuben is professor in the Department of
Engineering and public policy and in the
department of mechanical engineer he's
chair of the yellin professor of
environmental engineering and science
and founding director of the center for
energy and environmental studies and the
environmental Institute his BS is a
mechanical engineering from the city
college in New York and an MF s and PhD
from Stanford his teaching and research
in the area of energy utilization
environmental control with particular
emphasis on co utilization and carbon
sequestration he has served on the
advisory board for EPA Department of
Energy National Academy of Sciences and
Engineering and was the lead author in
the internet Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate Change on carbon capture and
storage which as you know has just been
named with Al Gore as a participant in
the Nobel Prize so mm-hmm thank you give
me a second media even though we're
computer you if not yet successfully
resolve the PC Mac dichotomy
yeah I can blame this on me I think will
show your age where neither of us era
let's see if that works this is always
the moment of truth okay if I do it one
more time I should okay now I get to see
it as well very good so the division of
labor that Granger and Lester and I
agreed to as Granger was going to give
the overview of climate Lester and I are
going to talk about what i SPECT most
you really came here to talk about how
to reduce greenhouse gas emissions I
will focus largely on the utility sector
but I want to get to it by first talking
about this issue and more more generally
first Oh Granger went through it quickly
just to recognize that when we talk
about greenhouse gases and the climate
change problem while carbon dioxide co2
is the main focus of attention properly
so because it's what we emit most of and
it has a long life there are other gases
as well methane in 20 is nitrous oxide
and a variety of other organic and
inorganic chemicals that have this same
affect the properties that they have in
common or that they trap incoming
sunlight and they all have very long
residence times in the atmosphere so
once you put them in the air they don't
go away very quickly just because of the
time constraints I want to focus on the
co2 problem part of what the science
community has been trying to do over the
last couple of decades is try to
understand how you can put these on a
common footing and there's a concept
called the global warming potential
which has evolved GWP and on that kind
of waited basis on kind of
a year time frame the co2 problem both
nationally and internationally has
something on the order of an eighty-five
percent effect of the total of the total
issue so it's clearly the 800-pound
gorilla in the room and that's the one I
want to focus on focus on today let's
talk about where co2 in the u.s. comes
from and it comes from the things we do
and the things we we like to have so the
end users our communities are lumped
here basically buildings residential and
commercial buildings industrial
processes and transportation and the
different color different colors show
different different fuels so here's
transportation with about a third of the
u.s. co2 emissions it's all blue meaning
it all comes from petroleum it's
basically a one energy source issue it's
burning gasoline when we look at
buildings and industrial processes is
it's more varied actually in buildings
the lightest boy at the top comes from
electricity we don't generate
electricity in our own homes and
buildings we'll talk about that in a
second and the other bars represent the
direct use of fuels so one of the things
that one has to understand is not only
what can be done in each of these
sectors but we're electricity which is
used in all of these sectors comes from
and that's what this picture is showing
a lot of people are still surprised to
learn that we still use coal in in this
country more than half of our
electricity nationally comes from coal
here in Pennsylvania it's actually a
more sizable fraction and that coal
alone contributes again about a third of
the total co2 emissions in the country
and the rest of the co2 emissions the
yellow bar comes from burning natural
gas which has increased a lot in in the
last couple of the last decade in
particular so a short take-home message
is that electric power plants electric
generation and vehicles together account
for about seventy-five percent or
three-quarters of the total
co2 problem ok kool from power oil from
vehicles those are the two issues that
we really have to have to get at here
are some projections that the Department
of Energy made earlier this year the
deal we puts out the Energy Information
Administration annually puts out an
annual energy outlook which currently
looks out to the year 2030 and they
publish what they call a reference case
scenario which has all sorts of
assumptions about the future trends and
prices future efficiency improvements in
technology one thing they are not
allowed to do by law though is to make
any assumptions about how policy will
change in the future so all of their
analyses are based on no change in in
current policy this reference case
scenario gets a lot of visibility a lot
of attention a lot of people believe it
to be a forecast raise your hand if you
think there will be no change in any
policy in the next 25 years I don't
either so we know that this is not going
to happen but it's still an indication
of what of what might happen absent any
policy driver and what we see are
increases in all sectors of the US
economy with the total co2 emissions
increasing by about a third from now to
to 2030 over the next next 25 years the
biggest part of that increase the
fastest growing sector is actually the
electric power sector electricity is
something where we're using more and
more of all the computers and electronic
gizmos that are new to us just in the
last decade or two actually one of the
fastest growing sources of power
generation that ain't gonna stop and so
with the electric sector alone it's
we're looking at about a forty percent
increase in co2 emissions and most of
that is coming in these scenarios from
projected significant increases
in the use of coal why because natural
gas which we've been building a lot of
in the last decade a sudden we got a lot
a lot more expensive coal is still
relatively inexpensive and when you
allow these fuels to compete in the kind
of models that produce this this
scenario these are the kinds of results
we get so what can you do to reduce co2
emissions not in a small way the key
point in Granger's talk was that if
we're trying to stabilize the
concentrations of these gases in the
atmosphere which is the international
goal that has been agreed to it's not
going to take a five or ten or fifteen
percent reduction in emissions it's
going to take a seventy eighty ninety
percent reduction in emissions over the
next century kind of kind of timescale
so we're talking about big moves on
small moves and that is one of the key
problems here so how do we do that let
me just go through a couple of slides
that we will probably want to talk a
little bit more about in the discussion
phrase one thing we could do is to
develop and use more efficient
technologies simply to reduce the demand
for energy without sacrificing the
amenities I would assert there is no
technology that we use today anything
from the light bulbs in this room to the
cars you drive to the refrigerators and
air conditioners and space heaters you
have at home that cannot be engineered
to use less energy and provide the same
service in fact in many cases we've made
remarkable advances in doing just that
but often it requires spending more
upfront to save energy during a life of
the issue of the of the technology
that's there's not always incentives
because often the people who buy stuff
aren't the people who gain the benefits
of using it and often in the marketplace
there is often a disincentive to have
products that are more expensive in than
your competitors so regulations have
played a role in prompting that and
there's just a lot more that can be done
basically across the board in all of the
areas shown here there are other things
that we can do to reduce the demand for
energy services and energy-intensive
products some of these and have nothing
to do with technology a lot of them have
to do with lifestyle changes driving
smaller cars instead of trucks
carpooling instead of one person per
vehicle those are the kinds of things
that can also make a difference other
broader things changes in Community
Planning and Development we've we've got
or sprawl that is contributing in large
part so how we live whether we build out
or up makes a big difference
transportation systems and an
infrastructure the kinds of products we
manufacture and various things related
agricultural practice all of these are
our things that that can involve us
individually and then finally in terms
of other things we can do that we've
already had some discussion of this
earlier today we can start to try to use
technologies that with energy sources
that have lower or no greenhouse gas
emissions that is trying to move away
from coal and oil toward the use of
things like natural gas which has about
if we for power generation has roughly
half the co2 per kilowatt-hour of
electricity compared to coal we've
already started the discussion of
nuclear power and a lot of people like
the idea of renewables wind biomass
geothermal solar and hydro all of these
are on the table all of these will be
players in any serious strategy to deal
with the climate issue but what is also
clear from a lot of thought and a lot of
analysis over the last decade is that
there's no silver bullet there's no
single solution every one of these
options have their own sets of issues
and
limitations that go with it the other
thing to keep in mind is just the scale
of deployment that you would need to
have significant reductions in the US
alone we'd be talking about either
retrofitting or replacing literally
hundreds of millions of buildings and
end use devices in widgets tens of
millions and new cars per year and
literally hundreds of power plants
around the country so it ain't going to
happen quickly it's going to require the
massive deployment of technology and a
massive scale and it's not going to
happen overnight there's one additional
approach to reducing co2 emissions that
was already mentioned earlier in the
steinbrenner session number of you
weren't here at that and I wanted to
spend a little more time on this because
it's probably the one that might be
least familiar to you because it's been
a relatively new player in in the mix of
things that have been talked about and
and and analyzed for addressing
greenhouse gas emissions and that's the
notion of technologies to capture and
sequester the co2 produced at power
plants and other large sources there's a
nomenclature issue here the term carbon
sequestration up until it gets the last
four or five six years has largely been
used in the context of what is now being
called terrestrial sequestration that is
the uptake of co2 from the air by trees
and vegetation and that actually has a
legal the word sequestration carbon
sequestration actually has legal
connotations in terms of treaties that
are geared geared toward that today that
term also now includes technological
methods to capture co2 from smokestacks
and large sources and put it somewhere
sequester it so that it stays out of out
of the atmosphere there are a number of
acronyms that have been developed CCS is
the one that seems to have emerged as
the
as the main way of talking about this
entity the its carbon capture and
storage or carbon capture and
sequestration depending on on your
choice okay let me tell you a little bit
about this and just kind of get you up
to speed us if you haven't seen it
before the notion basically is that here
are various brought this could be a
power plant or a chemical plant of some
sort something large that uses
carbonaceous fuels we talked about
fossil fuels it could also be biomass
and the notion is that their co2
produced in the processing of this on
the way of getting useful useful
products what we need to be able to do
is capture that co2 separate it from the
other gases that it typically is mixed
with compress it actually compress it
till it becomes a liquid that makes it
easy to transport it through a pipeline
to where you would inject it typically
in too deep into the ground into a
geologic formation to keep it out of the
atmosphere I'll talk a little bit about
that in more detail there are
potentially other ways of sequestering
co2 you actually could put it deep in
the ocean who their issues associated
with that there are a number of other
things that are kind of in lower in less
light font down there that have been
looked at which I want to talk about
geologic formations are the key issue
that are being looked at today why the
interest in CCS it's fundamentally comes
from the realization that in a world and
in a country that is eighty-five percent
reliant on fossil fuels for our energy
that's not going to change quickly or
rapidly so the notion is that fossil
fuels especially coal which is the most
carbonaceous of the fossil fuels that we
use is going to continue to be used for
many decades there's just no way of not
doing that easily and all of the
alternatives you can pick your favorite
whether its nuclear renewables or
whatever you like those are simply not
likely to achieve the large reductions
in co2
the time frames that are of interest to
the policy community so the reality is
that we're going to be putting more co2
into the air if we keep using these and
ccs then that captured storage
potentially would allow coal and other
fossil fuels to continue to be used with
little or no co2 emissions I like to
think of it as a bridging strategy to a
more sustainable future because it's
going to take time to develop all the
other things that we think could could
do that better job and a stranger just
mentioned it's also very interesting
it's the it offers actually for the
first time a potential link between what
we do to generate electricity or we do
to move ourselves around because we can
start to imagine an electrically driven
transportation system where the
electricity is carbon free we could
produce hydrogen from fossil fuels also
in a way that's carbon free but
sequestration is the key to making the
carbon free part of that work so it's
been getting a lot of attention the
other reason it's of interest is that
other one folks among these big energy
models to look at hundreds from around
the world to do that including this
capture and storage option in the
portfolio of all the other things i
mentioned actually saves a significant
amount of money it's kind of makes sense
any portfolio the ritual portfolio
typically the more effective it is and
and that's the case with this as well
there's a lot of detail on this
technology in a report that was produced
just about two years ago by the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change and i'd recommend you to their
website i would not recommend you read
the full technical report unless you
really want to dive into this start with
a ten page summary for policymakers it's
a very readable document and might be a
way to get started the leading
candidates for this basically are large
sources most of the co2 that we
currently emit and will be emitting for
the next decades will be a fossil fuel
power plants so that's the place to go
there are different types of plants
there are some large industrial sources
pipelines and geologic sequestration
are the ways that keep co2 out of me out
of the air there's a lot of activity
worldwide on this which is the other
part of part of the message there are
co2 capture projects around the world
this is not a new technology that needs
to be invented the technology for
separating and capturing co2 is
commercial it's been in use for many
decades most of the use has been not in
the electric power industry but in
petroleum and petrochemical plants such
as the one showing here on the on the
left it's also used in a in a coal
gasification plant in North in North
Dakota so it's commercial technology we
know how to do it we know what it costs
the same technology has actually been
used on on power plants here are two
examples of plants one in Oklahoma and
the other one in Maryland I'm not the
entire plant but only a small portion of
it is being treated for co2 capture
basically because co2 is an industrial
commodity people pay good money for it
both of these plants capture the co2 and
sell it across the fence typically to a
food processing plant that uses it and
then it goes out into the atmosphere so
it's been used in power plant
applications but on a scale it's about
an order of magnitude a factor of 10
smaller than a big commercial plant co2
pipelines are also nothing new I don't
know how many of you know about it I
didn't realize it until I started
getting to this business years ago but
we've got thousands of kilometers of co2
pipelines mostly in the western part of
this country a lot of it takes co2 from
natural sources just as you drill for
oil you could drill for co2 there's a
lot of natural co2 and the ground is
pretty cheap to get out and so what they
do is they take it out of places like
this and the ship it to rest Texas and
use it for this called enhanced oil
recovery has very lubricating properties
and and helps get more oil
ground and that's the major use of co2
we use about 40 million tons of co2 in
the country today for that purpose and
there are pipelines all over there have
been operating for for many decades
there's also a lot of activity
internationally on the sequestration the
geologic sequestration of co2 this map
shows a number of places around the
world there are three big projects big
meaning a million tons of co2 or more a
year here's a picture of two of them
these are both at plants that that that
develop natural gas natural gas when you
dig it out of the ground actually has a
lot of co2 mixed in with it and so that
co2 is typically separated out to get at
the gas we want and typically vented to
the atmosphere well about 15 years ago a
little less than that Norway put a tax
on co2 emissions for offshore operations
and that was enough to convince that oil
who are developing gas in the North Sea
to take the co2 and instead of putting
in the atmosphere put it back under the
ocean floor into what's called this deep
saline formation that's been going on
for over 12 almost 13 years now very
carefully watched and carefully
monitored facility this lower picture
here is in Algeria this is a BP plant
that came online about two years ago
bp's doing this on their own nickel just
to get some experience with it because
they think they can make some money
here's another recent project I
mentioned that there's a plant in North
Dakota that's actually using coal to
produce synthetic natural gas and in
that process again to produce natural
gas you normally have to separate co2
out and typically invent it to the
atmosphere well for the last two years
now about a million tons of that co2 has
been shipped to southern Saskatchewan
there's a 200 mile pipeline that was
built these are not big there's about 18
inch pipeline so that when
these huge things and it shipped as a
liquid basically and it's used for
enhanced oil recovery but in this case
it's also being used for and monitored
for permanent sequestration that co2 at
the end of at the end of the life when
one looks around the world again one of
the reasons that this has become a hot
topic is that as best we could tell
today there is a lot of acceptable
geologic storage capability around the
world in places where the co2 is so you
generally don't have to go very far from
these big sources to find geologic sites
that would be acceptable and what keeps
you out of the atmosphere there's a lot
of interest in some concern and
discussion about how safe is it if you
put it down there is it going to stay
there what's going to do to me we can
talk about that in the discussion bottom
line though is that the longer it stays
on the ground the safer it is and the
longer it's going to stay there because
over time the co2 begins to dissolve in
the brackish briny waters and over
longer periods of time it actually turns
into rock into carbonate rocks so it has
very different attributes than other
kinds of waste that we sometimes talk
about putting underground cost is a big
issue and these are not inexpensive
technologies there are lots of ways of
talking about cost I'm choosing one here
that's relatively simple because it's
it's it's a number you can remember and
kind of compared to some of the policy
numbers so if I put today's technology
on a power plant that burns coal and if
i have to pay some money to put it down
underground as opposed to somebody
paying me to get it out with enhanced
oil recovery something on the order of
fifty dollars per ton of co2 avoided is
what it's going to cost me there's
actually another way of generating an
electricity that has been gaining a lot
of attention because it affords a much
easier way of capturing the co2 and that
involves not burning coal
but gasifying it you might have heard
the acronym IGCC integrated gasification
combined cycle without co2 it's a
somewhat more expensive technology but
will co2 capture in most cases it's
actually cheaper than what we're doing
today and that comes in at something on
the order of thirty dollars per ton of
co2 avoided the kinds of legislative
proposals that are being talked about
here and which already in force in
Europe have carbon prices more on the
order of ten to fifteen dollars a ton of
co2 so there's no economic incentive for
this thing to happen right now under the
legislative proposals that are around
it's also important to understand we've
done a lot of work at Carnegie Mellon
here and looking at how things change
over time technology innovation is a
very powerful force but you need a
market for technologies to do that we
can see the cost coming down
significantly in the future if this
technology came on so here's some
results of some modeling studies that
show how carbon capture and other
options come into play in trying to meet
emission goals there are a number of
barriers to deployment first of which is
there's no reason to do it right now it
has high costs we don't have regulations
yet for details of putting in the ground
legal issues and lack of a lack of
experience a lot of these are the kinds
of things we're working on in research
here at Carnegie Mellon so this is my
take on Granger's uncertainty slide
futures and certain a lot of it will
have to do with how climate policy
develops thanks
very much that answers a lot of
questions okay well that is working with
his slides I'll introduce Lester we do
have somewhat of a time constraint
because president Cohen speeches at ten
Lester dave is professor of university
professor and Higgins professor of
economics at CMU he's appointments in
the business school and the engineering
school in the public policy all right
but one point I do want to make since I
mentioned that Granger was elected
natural science is that he's also been
elected to the Institute of Medicine the
National kind of science so we have
three various two people here one word
what one of the issue you've just heard
that technically we can we can do this
stuff the big fear got this is that it's
going to be so expensive it will ruin
our future that's really what I want to
talk about what other things if you're
not careful about this stuff then it can
be ruinously expensive if you are
careful about our best calculation is
that the amount of money in low-cost
United States will be about comparable
to what it is we spent on fading blue
tees in the 1970s and 1980s in the
united states air and water peters if it
is the back order of magnitude our
economy survived that and so if we do
this in a clever way our economy will
certainly survive this so this is just a
picture definitely appropriate for
computer you of what it is my
characterization is of current energy
policy right it says technical support
says first try rowing faster that's what
energy policy has been in the United
States
so the first thing I need to be straight
on is that for the last hundred fifty
years the whole industrial era has been
covered by cheap energy equally in the
United States better is gone right that
is if you think that gassing is going to
be a darn half gallon sometime in the
next few years you're smoking something
right that era is over and we have to
plan for future where energy is going to
be a lot more expensive than right now
but that's not a particular problem for
our economy to reason why energy is more
expensive is because of environmental
concerns and because of it's just more
expensive to get energy out of the
ground than it was in the past how our
reaction our whole economy has been
built on cheap energy that doesn't mean
that we can't turn this around it just
means that we've got to change things
the way did you know that there are more
than one car for licensed driver in the
United States right almost 1.2 cars for
licensed driver I have this picture of
getting to convertibles write a reggae
mop suck-ups right foot and one my left
foot in the other text you email up here
and go down the highway that's
ridiculous right well if you're driving
kk Hummer right or you're driving a ford
expedition something that's where that's
basically what you're doing right that
is your driving 5,000 6,000 pounds of
car down there and it's the equivalent
of having these two convertible so that
doesn't even take account of that that
is that energy is really cheap and we
have a lot of dog vehicles can United
States all right we had fuel economy
legislation in 1975 after
patti bahr go it said that we had to go
to 27.5 miles per gallon for automobiles
that's the top line the line that shown
up is black here you can see that we
achieved that and not 1980s and it
basically in there for a long time EPA's
estimate is that people we had kagan all
of the improvements can play in engines
and transmissions over that period of
time we'd be at about 33 miles per
gallon but we did we took all of the
improvements in terms of acceleration
are zero to 60 mile-per-hour time is a
fifty percent less than it was in 74 and
we took it in terms of larger heavier
cars and so we've gotten cars that
Americans like to drive more than they
did before but not in terms of fuel
economy in 1974 about ten percent of the
new vehicles sold for light trucks now
there's fifty percent of the vehicles
solar light trucks sports utility
vehicles pick up drugs minivans and so
on that's the bottom line at the graph
here again there was a fuel economy
standard for those of about twenty point
seven miles per gallon and those have
been flat for this period the yellow
line in between a little harder to see
is the fuel economy of the average new
vehicles sold which has been going down
because we have been bought what we have
bought more and more of these light
trucks
so what why are why is this important
well they talked about co2 I want to
turn away from co2 for a second right
we're actually since pending at the
moment about for 360 million dollars a
year of turmoil and I like this quote
for linen I come from a business school
right you know we're all luckily people
so confirmation one of the things we do
in our business school is at least I
read Lennon right we have a book that
says the capitalists are so hungry for
profits that they will sell us the road
and the width and i've added on a list
your life quote which is and they will
send us the money to buy the road so
what can we do about this stuff i am
chairman of a new panel for the national
academy of sciences worrying about
energy efficiency fuel economy and one
of the things we know how to do is we
know how to improve fuel economy by
hybrid electric cars that is not what we
are doing the hybrid electric cars you
buy now with the exception of the prius
one exception our built for power not
for fuel economy that ford escape hybrid
is a wonderful car to drive you step on
the accelerator came back with gold take
a look at the fuel economy of that it's
one mile per gallon greater than the
escape that doesn't have the hybrid
okay those are all geared for power a
dumb old Toyota mean toyota introduced
the prius 50 miles per gallon a really
fuel-efficient car right and detroit
then learn how to make these hybrids
that gave you power and they sold like
mad in the united states and so a toyota
since then has not made the same mistake
again that toyota lexus and so on are
now all cars that give you lots of
acceleration that's what Americans seem
to 15 but we can get the greater fuel
economy with cars that you would like to
drive our architects here told me and I
didn't believe that we can improve the
fuel the energy efficiency of a new
high-rise building by about 80% I since
talked about all sorts of people around
the world and they said yes yes that is
certainly true right and if you go to
the intelligent workplace here you can
see that that's a building you'd rather
work in rather than the one that you
currently work in we know how to improve
lighting and air conditioning by 50%
plus certainly with respect to lighting
if we can do all of those things with no
perceptible change in lifestyle right
that is that you wouldn't notice the
difference why don't we do that now the
answer is energy is just too cheap like
I mean you may think the three dollars
again at the pump is a lot go to Europe
you're talking about seven dollars down
those economies haven't collapsed under
that energy is simply too cheap in the
United States here's one solution for
how it is we can get rid of all gasoline
in the United State right and these are
using technologies that we currently
know about your not is economically
attractive
but we know about these technologies we
know that we can replace gasoline with
ethanol has it all that people are
talking about now is a blend of it
guessed gasoline and ethanol you go to
sunoco you can buy a plant that's ten
percent ethanol ninety percent gasoline
if you're going to have to Brazil you
will find that you can pull in a pump
and you can buy either gasohol which is
twenty-seven percent ethanol rest
gasoline or straight ethanol and you can
put any one of those in your flex fuel
vehicle that flex fuel vehicle is made
by GM Ford or Chrysler right and you
have to tell the vehicle anything just
put it in the evil knows everything
about it right and so we could do that
in the United States and what we
currently use 150 billion gallons of
gasoline a year we can't make enough
ethanol to replace that that would
require about 200 billion gallons of
ethanol replace that so that's too much
but if we had all these cars be hybrids
not with my fifty percent of well I
guess my perfect sense movement almost
done that would require 150 billion
gallons of ethanol that's still more
than we can do but there's this concept
called plug-in hybrid if you put a
battery in a car that will take the car
of 30 miles that will save two thirds of
the fuel that you use right thing is
that homes all the trips we make in the
united states are about 10 miles and we
drive our cars about 30 miles a day and
so if you have this 30-mile battery we
can
two-thirds of the fuel which means if we
had these plug-in hybrids that we would
need only 50 million gallons of ethanol
a year we can easily do that not with
corn corn is a big mistake but we can do
that with cellulose to cathun all enthan
all made from wood chips from grasses
and so on and we can do that relatively
inexpensively what if you're going to do
it then what we need to do is to have
some floor in the price of oil and
eighty dollars a barrel he is a floor
that would certainly work we're above
that now no big deal about that here's
my last slide these are data from our
department of energy not I didn't make
them up and there's a comparison just
look at the top tube between denmark in
the united states the first of the last
column over there is BTU per capita
which is basically income per capita if
you look at denmark vs the US this is
2002 the things were slightly richer
than we were don't believe the numbers
particularly I don't know what the
difference looks like basically the same
if we now go to the first column it
tells you energy use per dollar GDP more
at forty five percent or sorry the Danes
are at forty five percent of where we
are we used twice as much more there
twice as much energy for dollar GDP as
the Danes use the middle cone is energy
use per public for population again the
Danes use less than half of what we use
anybody ever been to Copenhagen and one
they want their foot
right days look pretty well right I mean
if you can't tough me and you made me go
to Copenhagen to live I don't I wouldn't
cry a lot right I mean that's a really
pleasant lifestyle half less than half
the energy didn't use right and and that
is not a mild climate particularly all
right so so the point of this slide is
that there's a lot we can do in the
United States we would have to change
our lifestyles the gains have fewer cars
per capita the cars they have drives
fewer miles per year it can't believe
more in high-rise buildings that can
take a more public transportation and so
on those are certainly all things that
that way you do the point of this is
that just to sum up the first point is
that if we're going to do these things
we're talking about we need to pay a lot
of attention to what the costs are we
don't we will not be penalizing the
economy if we can do these in economic
way and there are several ways in which
we can do them that are almost free at
the moment in terms of increasing
efficiency and then more generally if we
want to get our eighty percent
reductions which we can do then it's
going to take some lifestyle changes as
well and you know I'll then expose
myself to the world and say do you
really need to have one person driving a
hummer work right I mean if you look at
the highway about one part you can will
have more than one person in so do you
need to have this this huge vehicle
6,000 pounds
whatever is with one person inside
wouldn't it be just as well gift if you
had a Prius Akbar I've been in the back
seat as well as the throne Ziva prius
right suppose it that we have one person
for carving that would we be breaking
the hearts of America off and so I think
the kinds of lifestyle changes that
we're talking about her also perfectly
good at this point let's stop I think
that we're going to try and try
sometimes request we have one additional
speaker that his pretty Coco shoes
secretary Ministry of Environment and
Forests for the governor India and he
has just recently been one of the
honorees of Carnegie Mellon Alumni
Association so just come up with safety
words and so what I'll do is I'll skip
my presentation and just make some you
know observations extent pari okay you
know like we give some you know Granger
mentioned about the new delhi experiment
with you know with conversion of the
vehicles fleet to compressed natural gas
this was motivated not so much by
climate change concerns as by local air
quality concerns and what this
essentially required was conversion of
the entire bus fleet almost the entire
taxi fleet and then of course in
developing countries you have these
three wheeler taxis you know they call
by various names in different countries
and the conversion of that entire fleet
to see NJ now of course what has
happened is that as a consequence but
not entirely as a consequence of this
change over there has been a tremendous
improvement in air quality in the city
of Delhi which it's very obvious i mean
if you if you were there five years ago
and if you're there now there's a huge
huge difference but this is not the only
thing that happened there were several
other things that happen in the jury is
still out on precisely what the what do
you know
but the conversion of how much of this
change is actually due to this cng
conversion now this was a massive effort
because it involved retrofitting
existing vehicles involved freezing out
of old vehicles it involved creating
entire new infrastructures for supply of
the natural gas and there was actually
you know because this was a very hard
regulation which was enforced very
strictly by the courts this resulted in
significant you know disruption for a
period of several months in the
transportation system but the result
said there's also that of course have
been at least significant decay
significant extent that this has had the
major impact on air quality it may have
had a significant impact also on the GHG
emissions but once again we don't know
for sure because you know we have to
really to the empirical work to
determine how much of the of the savings
in carbon emissions from combustion of
cnts of signature leakages of of CNG
methane you know has a very high global
warming potential now of course we had
the first speaker who's who spoke great
extensively about buildings now let me
tell you about you know the Indian
program with respect to buildings large
buildings in India they are subject to
two kinds of regression in respect of
the environment and energy efficiency we
have the environmental impact assessment
requirement for buildings which have an
activity area of 20,000 square meters or
more and we have the energy the
building's energy code and that goes for
that goes down to a smaller activity
area probably about five thousand square
meters i saw the environmental impact
assessment requires that each building
which qualifies for regulation to submit
an environment management plan and the
environment management plan of course it
relates to dimensions of energy use it
relates to water conservation it relates
to building you know
waste management it required relates to
recycling of used water there are many
different dimensions that it relates to
landscaping and there is a point system
and a star dating system now the the
developer is free to choose combinations
of various measures under each of these
categories and each has a certain you
know weight is in terms of this of the
rating scale there are some which are
mandatory and of course you know he's
required to do the mandatory you know
measures and he doesn't earn any points
of that but then there's a qualifying
level if it's below those qualifying
marks then he doesn't get invariance
back to the drawing board but then if he
does better than that then depending on
the actual qualifying actual actual bar
you know scores achieved there is a star
rating you know gold silver bronze which
go which which are given for buildings
which you know exceed the normative
requirement there are there's also the
building building code energy energy
code which again provides for many of
measures in respect of lighting in
respect of space cooling in respect of
insulation and so on now at this point
the building energy efficiency code is
voluntary and the idea is to get the you
know building sector you know accustomed
to these measures to create a market for
you know for these technologies but then
of course the idea is that in due course
this will be made mandatory let me let
me at this point give some examples the
Institute which I am which I am
associated Teddy all its properties are
green buildings and there is a campus
which is close to the city of New Delhi
if you visit digital a can arrange a
visit which is energy neutral all its
energy requirements are met from solar
and biomass there is water complete
water recycling there is a very
innovative in a system of space
condition
by which you know the by which air is
actually circulated below the ground at
a depth of more than 2 meters and that's
that's a point at which there is
basically a stable temperature
throughout the year so this means that
in the course of 12 months of the year
they're only about two months where
supplemental cooling is required but all
the space conditioning requirements are
met by this met by the system now I
think you know that you know have we run
out of time so i will stop stop here
thank you for the opportunity of making
this presentation